d'âge les salariés de sanofi sont en
colère ils veulent le faire savoir
absolument et la manifestation se
poursuit depuis et très tôt ce matin 4
heures pour les premiers arrivants et
les revendications et bien sont les
mêmes une augmentation de salaires une
prime de 2000 euros pour tous ceux qui
ont travaillé en période de crise
sanitaire alors les négociations de
décembre n'ont abouti à rien et à les
syndicalistes et bien promettent déjà de
continuer cette grève de la prolonger
s'ils n'obtiennent pas gain de cause
un mouvement qui a bien bénéficié du
soutien de françois ruffin député de la
france en soumises de la somme bonjour
merci d'être avec nous racontez nous
pourquoi est ce que vous avez fait le
déplacement
aujourd'hui sur ce site de val-de-reuil
moi ça fait des années que je suis sur
sanofi à savoir que j'observe la casse
d'un outil industriel bon ça ça arrive
ailleurs un ca river dans le plu
matticks arrive dans l'ameublement ou
non de la finance mais surtout la la
casse d'un outil sanitaire l'an dernier
en plein coeur finement on annonce quoi
enfin sanofi annonce point annonce 4
milliards d'euros de dividendes pour les
actionnaires et non c'est à dire le
record de tous les temps qui est battu
et dans la foulée 1750 suppressions de
postes dont 2000 en france en dix ans
qu'est ce qui s'est produit il ya eu la
moitié des postes de chercheurs qui est
en sus ont été supprimés chez sanofi en
le monde comme en france il ya eu plus
de recherche en neurologie pull
recherche sur le diabète fulgurant
cherche les antibiotiques des pans
entiers de la recherche comme ça qu'ils
ont été abandonnés
on avait onze centres de recherche en
france il ya des ya dix ans il y en a
quatre aujourd'hui et devront rester 3 à
la fin de l'année donc voilà on a un
véritable déshabillage de la recherche
chez moi ça me paraît dramatique pour
les salariés
évidemment puisque ce sont des emplois
qui sont supprimés mais ça me paraît
aussi dramatique pour tous les français
puisque ben là on se retrouve dans une
situation de dépendance à l'égard des
américains qui nous donnent des doses
nous donne pas des doses on n'est pas
leur priorité l'europe n'est pas sa
priorité et la france encore moins la
france et sanofi en particulier était
un des grands espoirs en matière de deux
vaccins au tout début de la crise
sanitaire aujourd'hui on la france a été
prise de court et le vaccin français
prend du retard
qu'est ce que vous avez à dire à ce
niveau là ce qu'on peut parler de fiasco
déjà bah oui c'est un fiasco évident
maintenant la question c'est comment on
pourrait espérer que un vaccin germes
d'un seul coup alors qu'on a désorganisé
la recherche désorganisé l'audience du
trial désorganisé le développement
pendant dix ans c'est pas parce qu'on
met 600 millions d'euros sur la table et
qu'on dit on va on va lancer le vaccin
que d'un seul coup tout se rétablit des
chaînes de production des chaînes de
développement des chaînes de recherche
c'est du travail dans la durée avec des
gens qui se connaissent qui se
rencontrent et instituts et donc voilà
ça ça a été cassé et on peut pas espérer
que que ça rhône s du jour au lendemain
qu'on fait tout à l'heure que le
gouvernement l'absence de réaction du
gouvernement et à ce sujet là vous
pensez que le gouvernement peut et doit
dire quelque chose
là il ya un certain nombre de choses à
faire si on est le gouvernement d'abord
comme je le réclame tous les ans à un
moment du budget on peut cesser de
donner du crédit impôt recherche à une
multinationale qui détruit la recherche
c'est la première chose mais là on peut
supposer la fermeture du centre de
strass de recherche de strasbourg
on peut le gouvernement a quand même les
moyens de se poser des choses comme ça
est très concrètement aujourd'hui sur le
vaccin
le gouvernement pourrait utiliser la
licence droit la licence pour attraper
le vaccin astrazeneca par exemple le
faire produire en réquisition sur les
sites de sanofi ça serait l'une des
pistes envisageables fois que ça allait
beaucoup plus vite rires le le côté
tragique de ça c'est que nous on ne va
nous demander encore de fermer nos
lumières de rentrer chez nous à 18h le
soir peut-être de nour confiné tu avoir
le droit d'aller balayer nos chiens
faire du jardinage et tout ça à plus
d'un kilomètre de chez nous pendant
qu'il ya des français qui sont disposés
à se faire vacciner on à moi dans mon à
abbeville par exemple dans mon coin
on était à 750 doses par semaine
normalement on devait accélérer donc
augmenter ça on va repasser à 509 parce
qu'on n'a pas les il n'ya pas les
vaccins pour ça moi je suis pour que les
gens qui ont envie de se faire vacciner
puisse le faire
et les gens qui veulent pas se faire
vacciner on les embête pas mais là
aujourd'hui les gens qui veulent se
faire vacciner
ne peuvent pas merci beaucoup françois
ruffin de nous avoir accordé ces
quelques minutes donc vous l'avez
entendu le député de la samain de la
france en sommet ce qui déplore le fait
est bien que la france ait perdu son
indépendance en matière de l'industrie
pharmaceutique notamment
merci nadège abderrazak en direct donc
du site de sanofi et de val de reuil en
dans le département de l'eure en
normandie